FEMALE SPEAKER: Please join me
in welcoming to Google New York
Adam Braun.
[APPLAUSE]
Adam and I were chatting a
bit before you guys came in
and I was telling him
that this book is really--
it's an amazing story.
It really captures the
spirit of the organization
and how it started.
But I thought something that
was a really interesting thread
throughout the book was this
exploration journey internal
and also throughout the world.
Can you tell me how
that started for you?
ADAM BRAUN: A great question.
So for those that aren't
familiar with the book,
it's first and
foremost the story
of turning $25-- which is how
I started the organization--
to now more than 200
schools globally.
But along the way, it
provides the guiding steps
to a life of both
success and significance.
I think for a long time,
previous to the current era,
you almost have to
choose one or the other.
You could have what we deem
success or more purpose
or meeting and
philanthropy in your life
and nowadays there's this
beautiful intersection
that's occurring.
So the book is really
written to help individuals
find their own path
to achieving both.
And it's framed
around 30 mantras.
So every chapter is a very
short, quick vignette--
an individual story and their
titles with these mantras
that are guiding steps
like a central truth
that I found helpful
over the years.
And I would write in
journals or on white boards.
And one of them is get
outside of your comfort zone,
or get out of your comfort zone.
And I think it speaks
to the question
that you asked because
I think part of it
is maybe because I was a middle
child and middle children,
you're given the
freedom to explore.
Because people are
paying attention
to your oldest and
your younger siblings.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
a middle child, too.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
You have this recognition
pretty early on have
that you have a freedom that's
afforded to you by virtue
of your birthplace.
And I started to--
really in college,
I think-- recognize when I
was a sophomore or junior,
I started to get into
music really heavily.
And I decided for
a semester or two
that I was just not going
to buy any of the textbooks
that my classes assigned.
And I spent the money instead
on creating my own curriculum.
And that meant that I bought
all of these biographies
of the rock-- the Rolling
Stones and Bob Dylan-- some
of the other musicians
that I was into
and I decided to read
their life stories
as well as some of the
really influential books
that you're almost supposed
to read in your early 20s.
And what I found
was that the artists
that I really
revered-- when I looked
at their history of
their music they never
created great music
or art or literature
during periods of contentment.
It was never when
things were going well
and they were happy and
peaceful that their greatest
songs were written.
It was always during
periods of struggle.
Culture was at odds in
some way, shape or form.
There was societal unrest.
They just had their
heartbroken, maybe.
There was a passing,
some level of adversity.
And that's when these explosive
creative breakthroughs happen.
And so, at that point in time,
I was a sophomore becoming
a junior and I was playing
basketball at Brown
and I had a girlfriend and I
was really happy with my life.
And for some reason,
I was like, I just
need to be uncomfortable.
I have to find a way to
get out of my comfort zone
and that led me to
go on Semester at Sea
and on Semester at Sea a series
of things happened that I think
changed my perspective
pretty drastically on I
wanted to spend my life.
But it was that
kind of recognition
of how those that
I had admired most
have lived their
lives that led me
to this kind of
exploratory nature.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Don't you think you
could talk about
the Semester at Sea?
Because that's actually
my next question request
is-- in the book
and also in speeches
that Adam has given he
talks about this Semester
at Sea experience.
And it's not the idyllic
Semester at Sea experience.
And can you just talk
to us a little bit
and briefly tell everybody
what your experience was like?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
So for those that aren't
familiar, Semester at Sea
is a cruise ship that
goes around the world.
And you most the time stop
in anywhere from EIGHT
to 13 countries--
every voyage has
a slightly different itinerary.
But my year it was supposed
to be 10-- different countries
across Asia, Africa
and Latin America.
And I'm part of one of
the three famous voyages.
And you don't get
famous on Semester
at Sea unless something
goes really wrong.
So my ship left from
Vancouver headed
toward South Korea,
January, 2005.
And while crossing
the North Pacific--
it was the very first time
that they had gone that route.
They always went
the other direction.
But they had a brand
new ship my year
and they decided that
it was OK to cross
the North Pacific in winter.
And three major storm
fronts developed.
We tried to go underneath,
and another one
developed underneath us.
And we got caught in
essentially a superstorm.
And there's a 30 minute
"Storm Stories" episode
just on my ship that's on
YouTube that can look up.
But we were struck
by 60 foot rogue wave
about 800 miles from land.
And it went over
the top of our ship
and it shattered the glass on
the sixth floor bridge, which
housed all the navigational
equipment and the power
to our engines.
And so we lost all
power to our engines
while in 45 foot
swells surrounded
by freezing cold
hypothermic water.
And I had a certain
death experiencing.
I mean, the announcement
came telling
us to get to the
fifth floor or higher,
help the women and
children up the stairs,
keep on your life jackets,
and to your muster stations.
And for those that
aren't familiar,
a muster stations is where
you evacuate a ship from.
So we were basically
told-- without saying it
explicitly-- the ship's going
down and you have to evacuate.
And I'm looking out at a small
mountain of freezing cold water
with no ability to
get into lifeboats.
And so I was sure I was
dying in the next hour,
there was no doubt in my mind.
Went through the emotional
experience of that.
And about 30 or 45 seconds
in-- and I try and detail it
in the book but it's hard
to articulate it all--
FEMALE SPEAKER:
You do a good job.
ADAM BRAUN: Thank you.
I just have this total calm,
stillness, settle over me
and it was recognition--
not like belief or hope--
but recognition that I
was not going to perish.
I just knew it.
And within that recognition,
there was the knowledge
that if I'm not meant
to die today, then
there's something
else that gives me
that knowledge,
which is purpose.
That my life is not meant
to be a 21-year-old man who
perishes at sea-- that I have
some purpose in being here.
And from that point
forward, I just became
relentlessly committed to the
pursuit of individual purpose,
and sought to find
what that thing was.
And eventually other
experiences led me to find it
and then it manifested into
this organization, Pencils
of Promise.
FEMALE SPEAKER: From that
kind of purpose-- that moment
I'm here for a reason
I'm here for a purpose.
ADAM BRAUN: And I believe that
about every single person.
And I think every
single person--
anyone who is
sitting in this room
or watching this
online-- I distinctly
believe that you have
an individual purpose.
Your existence is for a
reason, and ultimately
the most powerful thing that you
can do is discover what that is
and live it fully because
then you become unstoppable.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I like that.
Very cool.
So the ship almost went down--
it didn't go down, thankfully.
ADAM BRAUN: Spoiler alert.
I survived.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Yes, he survived.
Thank God.
And I guess the organization
was started or at least was
created from this question
that you were asking kids
of what do you
want most in the--
ADAM BRAUN: In the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If you
could have one thing,
what would it be?
How did you-- why did you
start asking that question?
Do you remember?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
In general I've always
found that it's better
to come in as a
listener than a speaker.
And I'm naturally
introverted and I was not
comfortable going
up to strangers
and starting up a conversation.
But at the time, I think, when
you're college kid you almost
envision your cool idea of
what your room is going to be.
And when you go on
a Semester at Sea
you almost know that everyone
does one thing for a country.
Like they got a beer cap from
each country, or a t-shirt
or they take a
photo with a Beanie
Baby in front of a tourist spot.
Yeah, you know what
I'm talking about.
They really did that.
And so I decided that rather
than having push pins of where
I went, I'd always
been interested in kids
and worked with kids.
And so I thought, let me ask
one child in each country
that I go to, what do you
want most in the world?
And this way I can start up
a conversation with anybody
just by asking a
question, and I'll
have them write it down
on a piece of paper.
And then when I
get back I'll have
this collage of global interest.
But I assumed they were going
to be the material things that
wanted.
I thought it was like a kid in
China is going to want a house,
and a kid in Brazil is going
to want a professional soccer
team.
It was all these
big material ideas
that were worth lots of money.
And I detail in the book
that the first answer I got
was to dance.
A young girl said no,
you can always enroll,
but her answer was to dance.
In China it was a book-- girl
hadn't owned a book before.
In Hong Kong it was magic,
which I thought was my favorite.
And then in India where this boy
was begging on the street and I
though, OK he's going
to be my one kid.
His answer was a pencil.
And it was just such
a disarming answer
and when I gave him my
pencil he was so excited.
And at that point, I
realized for the first time
my life that they were kids
that lived without any access
to quality education-- which
is the one thing that lifted
my family out of property--
from Holocaust survivors
in a rural village on a
countryside to the life
that I was able to
live going to school
and great public
education system.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Two generations.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And so I thought maybe
this is my purpose
is to help create a world
in which every single child
on Earth-- regardless of where
you were born, regardless
of your socioeconomic
status-- has
access to quality education.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So after you
went on this amazing journey
and you went back, you
got a job at Bain, right?
That was your first of that job.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And then you
started your organization
during that process.
ADAM BRAUN: Mm-hmm.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Looking back, if you
were to do it a
different way, would you?
Or would you go back
and do it the same?
ADAM BRAUN: So, I
think, if I wanted
to create a more successful
organization-- larger in scale
or impacted more lives
than we have thus far.
As a what would be
second-time entrepreneur--
I've learned a
lot along the way.
And so I realistically would
have taken the advice that I
got which I speak about in the
book from one of my mentors,
George, who said to me-- this is
a very tough period it was late
2008, a bunch of companies
had just declared bankruptcy,
everyone was losing
their jobs in New York,
it was not a good time for
philanthropic capital--
and he said to me, you cannot
build an organization off
of small donations from young
people especially through this
social media thing you
keep on telling me about.
And so he said, go with
five donors who can give you
$50,000 each, and you have
$250,000 in startup capital,
and then you can hire a
team and build from there.
And if I was-- knowing
what I know now,
I probably would
go in and say yeah,
I should get a bunch of
high-net worth individuals
and get a bunch of
capital and then you
can springboard from
that point forward.
But I was so committed to
proving that any person can
create something of
large scale-- change--
that I was willing to
go into a bank and say
what does it take to
start a bank account.
And they said $25 to open up
something at Bank of America.
And so I put $25 in because one,
I didn't have a lot of money,
and two, my friends certainly
had no money at the time,
and I wanted to prove
that this could be done.
And so--
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
were 24 at the time?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, it
was my 25th birthday
at the launch of
the organization.
And so--
FEMALE SPEAKER: $25.
ADAM BRAUN: Right.
Right.
And so if I was purely committed
to building the organization
up, maybe I would have done
it a little bit differently.
But the ambition has
never been to solely
make Pencils of
Promise successful.
It's to change the thinking that
people have around philanthropy
and what we call a
nonprofit-- and I
like to call for-purpose
organizations--
and hopefully inspire
people and then
provide them with
the tools and ability
to create their own
extraordinary journey that
fulfills their sense of purpose.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So with
that $25 that you started,
besides that-- almost
more advice to people that
are interested in starting
their own side-organization
or organization-- what else are
the bare bones that you think
that you need to
start an organization?
You could forget the 5
giant $50,000 donation,
but what are the bare bones
that you would advise?
ADAM BRAUN: So there's
a lot, but if I
was to distill it into,
let's say, three things.
The first one is you
have to knowledge
that it's going to work.
And I'm not talking
about hope, and I'm not
talking about belief.
You have to be completely
delusional about the fact
that your idea is
going to succeed,
because you're going to
hear no, or that's nice
but I'm not interested,
99.9% of the time.
Even to this day, I
hear 99.9% of the time
I explain to somebody what
we do and they make a choice
not to support
Pencils of Promise.
Just by their own volition, so--
FEMALE SPEAKER: You'll hear
no way more than you hear yes.
ADAM BRAUN: Right.
Right.
And so the first is you
can't think it's a good idea,
you have to genuinely
believe that no matter what
anybody else says this
thing has to succeed.
And that, again, when it comes
from a place of purpose, which
is beyond passion,
that's step number one.
The second one is--
there's a chapter called
"Find The Impossible
Ones," which
is you need to find your tribe.
And I really advocate for people
almost creating an underdog
sense around your organization
or your company or your idea.
Because people rally
around underdogs.
There's a reason that
we watch March Madness.
It's not in hopes that the
final bracket is 1, 1, 1, 1.
It's that we want to see 8s
play against 15s and 15s win
and somehow make it.
Like that's the
stories that we love
and the stories that we tell.
And so as much as people
tell me this is impossible,
I thought, well, that's great.
I'm going to create a tribe.
Like our team is going to be
people that embrace that idea.
And so you have to have
like-minded individuals who
become your early adopters.
Because otherwise you're just
a lunatic preaching something
that nobody believes in.
And then the third
one is I genuinely
believe that you have
to combine business
acumen with the ideals found
your company, whether it's
a nonprofit or for profit.
But I've seen way too
many failed projects,
nonprofit or for
profit, because people
go into the space
with purely passion
and they're not equipped
with business acumen.
And I think that more
than anything that's
what's enabled us to
succeed is the training
that I had working at a hedge
fund when I was 16 or Bain
out of college.
It differentiated
me in the space.
And the reason that we are
successful in our programs
is because the business
acumen drives what we do.
It's not just pretty pictures
and a flashy website.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So in the midst of all
of this growing in your--
it's an amazing organization.
Why did you decide
to write a book now?
What was the motivation?
ADAM BRAUN: There
was a few things.
The first was that I had a
lot of people coming to me
and asking the natural question
of saying, I have an idea.
How did you turn $25 into
this big organization?
Can you just sit with
me for 30 minutes?
And after I did a bunch of
these phone calls and meetings,
I found that I was often
inspired by the feedback
that I was getting from them.
But I didn't have the
time or the ability
to give them all the
advice that I wanted.
So the first thing was
literally to create
a guidebook for any
other individual
to pursue their thing,
whatever that might be--
side job within a company,
something entrepreneurial.
But I read a lot of
these great books
and they were purely
inspiring narratives.
And they didn't have
the how-to element.
So that was the first thing
was I wanted to show people
how they could go and do it.
And then the second one was
that I wanted the organization
to continue and
scale its impact.
And either I could
get on a plane
and try and speak on
every stage possible,
or I could write something
that somebody else could
hand to somebody
else and say, oh, you
want to learn about
this organization?
Read this book.
And as part of that, all
proceeds from the book
go back to the organization.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's great.
ADAM BRAUN: And so it made it a
very easy decision for somebody
to say to another
individual, hey,
if you are interested
in learning
about a great organization,
here's the PoP book.
And this will provide with the
full background and the ability
to either get involved
with this organization
or to discover your own
passion and pursue it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: From the
time that this idea came up
to the time was
published, how long
was this process of writing it?
ADAM BRAUN: So one of
my bucket-list items
was to write a book,
just because I think
that it outlives the individual
and it was just a cool idea
that 100 years from now
there'll be some digital library
that Google has created
and this book will
be in the digital library
that people can go and see
with their robot eyes.
So the idea has been
there for a long time,
but the actual process
of writing was quick.
I mapped it out
with my co-writer,
Carly, over no more than
really three months.
And then I took a
sabbatical last year
with my fiance and
just a backpack each.
We did around the world
trip for a little bit more
than three months.
And I brought a
computer in the backpack
and so I would write most days
and send my draft back to Carly
and she would give me
her little revisions
and be like, pull out this
story, and more description
here, and really
guide me through it.
And so the entire
manuscript was actually
written in three months,
which is really fast.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
incredibly fast.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
And the original mentions
was 81,000 words,
and the final book is 66,000.
So a fair amount was
actually cut out,
but that was because I
wanted it to be an easy read.
I wanted it to be something
that you could pick up
in the airport on a
flight cross-country
and read it by the
time that you landed.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
I read it about two days.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
I mean, that's been the most
consistent feedback thus far
is I've read your book in no
more than three days for most
people.
It's like a weekend read
or flight read or their
on the beach for the afternoon
and they just tear through it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
it's a great read.
Something that you
talked about earlier
or brought up that I thought
was a really clever in the book
is the way the chapters
are named after mantras.
Why did you decide to
name them after mantras?
ADAM BRAUN: So somebody
asked me at one point,
there were 650 or 700 students
that went on your Semester
at Sea voyage.
What was it that was
different about you
that you came back with
not only this feeling
but then you converted
intention into action.
And the truth is, if I
think about what led to it,
I think it was the fact
that I just adopted mantras.
And so I've always had
one powerful phrase
that guides my decision-making.
And it's tough to
have a set of values
that you live by if
there's eight of them.
But I think it's really simple
if you find one essential truth
that you almost treat
as the guiding principle
that you make all
your decisions around.
And I find that oftentimes
I discover one phrase
or I come up with
one phrase and that
feels right for that
period of my life.
And so given that I
found these phrases so
helpful in my
decision-making process,
I thought, the way we
consume media nowadays
is really different.
So we want 140 characters
that describe something,
and then we want the ability
to click in an expand.
And so when I read, most of
the time it's tough for me
to read a whole book.
I don't about you guys, but I'm
like eight-- there's probably
eight books right now
that I'm between 50
and 100 pages through.
And I just kind of get
bored and I put it down.
I'm like, all right, I
get the general principle.
And so the one thing that I do
stick with is short stories.
So I listen to Moth Podcasts.
And I watch TED
Talks, and I like
episodes of "House of Cards"
and "Game of Thrones,"
and I like to watch
three if I want, or one.
So I thought, why
can't you write a book
with that same ideology,
the same kind of framework.
So the mantras could be the
quick way to access something.
And I'm sure you would agree.
Someone could pick up this
book and read Mantra 13 alone,
separate from the rest, and
feel like they gain value.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's very true.
ADAM BRAUN: And so
I wanted to write
in the way we consume
media nowadays as well,
like episodic versions,
and ultimately the Mantras
seemed like the best
way to frame it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It does
feel like episodes.
Like each chapter does
really feel like an episode.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, and I was
talking to a friend of mine
yesterday who's written
a really fantastic book.
And one of the things that
I was sharing with him
is that when I wrote the book I
was traveling for three months.
And I wanted to read great
books while I was traveling.
And what I found is that
there is, and I won't name it,
there's one book that was
an international bestseller
on a topic that I'm
so interested in,
but as I read it
was really dense.
It was like a textbook.
And it wasn't enjoyable
for me to read.
But when I thought about
the books that I did
enjoy they were kind
of these page turners
that left little hooks
at the end of a chapter
when I'd want to kind of put
it down and go get lunch.
I'd almost be like,
but, wait, I need
to know what happens next,
because he or she previewed
what's about to happen.
And so selectively--
it probably happens
six or seven times
throughout the book--
but at the end of a chapter
I would just kind of
plug in what's
coming next, and then
paint that scene in the next
paragraph on the side page.
And I found that it's
really enabled people
to kind of like watch the next
episode, if that makes sense.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
What was your biggest
discovery writing this book?
ADAM BRAUN: I think
the biggest discovery
was how valuable failures are.
You know, I got to a
point about, maybe,
six weeks before the book
went to physical print
where I had one final
ability to edit the material.
And at that point in time
you're really only supposed
to be editing a few words,
maybe a sentence here and there.
And there's a chapter called
"Fess Up To Your Failures,"
which is about a point
in time where I really
acted like a jerk to our staff.
Basically two of
our staff members
were held up at knife point and
robbed, and kind of roughed up,
a man and a woman in Guatemala.
And they were in a
community that they really
weren't supposed
to be in, and it
was after like a
Super Bowl party.
And so they emailed me
saying, we were roughed up,
and our passport and our
wallets, and our mobiles
were stolen.
And I thought that they
wanted reimbursement.
And I pretty much emailed
them back and said,
I'm so sorry that this
happened, but we're not
going to reimburse you,
because we value every dollar,
and you made the decision
to go on into this place.
And I really felt like I was
protecting Pencils of Promise,
when in fact I was actually
damaging the individuals which
make up the organization.
The organization is nothing more
than a collection of people.
And they were really
offended by it,
and they were like, we weren't
even asking for reimbursement.
We just wanted to notify
you that this happened.
And I really had to take a
kind of rough internal look,
and say, all right, what type
of leader do I want to be,
and was really
apologetic to them.
And the whole chapter
is about exclusively
failure on a personal level.
And six weeks before
the book came out
I just decided to take out the
chapter, because I was like,
I don't want to look like a jerk
to the thousands of people that
are hopefully going
to read this book.
And you're kind of
worried about criticism.
And, you know, there's
other chapters.
"Practice Humility
Over Hubris" is also
about where I made a
mistake, but this one
was like really being a jerk.
And so I told a few
people that had read it,
including my publisher, that
I'm taking out that chapter,
and I told a few of
our staff members.
And there was an
overwhelming response.
At least 90% of the people
that had read the book that I
informed that I was
taking out that chapter
came back and said, that was my
favorite chapter in the book,
because it showed
that you are human,
and it showed that you
make serious mistakes.
And there was a line at
the end of the chapter that
said, we learn far more from
the methods in which we address
failure than the moments
in the midst of success.
And that line really
resonated with people.
And so I decided to put
the chapter back in because
of their feedback, and
it's been one of the ones
that people point to most.
When I ask, what do you
remember, they're like the fact
that you were so honest
about your mistakes.
And when I look at the Amazon
reviews or any other review,
that's consistent
feedback is the book
is written with an honesty
and a vulnerability.
And that's something that I
didn't expect going into it,
that the failures
would resonate so much
with people rather
than the successes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
like that chapter too.
I'm glad you kept it in.
ADAM BRAUN: I'm glad everyone
loves my [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER:
It's good, because I
feel like it's towards the
end of the book too, right?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, I think
it's the 23rd or 24th chapter.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's very cool.
I mean, you're watching this
rise of your organization's
success, and you do have
this moment of humility.
ADAM BRAUN: I mean,
there's another chapter,
"Vulnerability is
Vital," which is
all about my fear of
asking people for money.
At three and a half
years in I hadn't
sat in front of one
person and said,
can you give $5,000
to the organization?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Which is amazing.
ADAM BRAUN: Right.
I mean, I articulated a vision
that I was delusional about,
and still am.
And people either
chose to donate or not,
and that was it,
because I didn't
want to ask anyone for money.
And then I recognized it
was such as big weakness
that it was holding
back our growth,
and that I need to admit to
my board of directors, which
are these huge business
leaders, that I was actually
bad at something,
not that I was great.
And it was in the
acknowledgement
of that vulnerability
that they said, OK, we
want to invest in
you getting better.
And I went through
the top course
at Harvard run by two
global experts on the space.
And the biggest
thing that I realized
is it was my sense of ego,
that I was putting myself
in the middle of the equation,
that if I asked you for money,
I felt like you were
giving money to me.
When in fact you're
actually supporting
Mit, and Noot, and Timone,
and some of our students
in the field, and you're not
giving money to me at all.
You're facilitating their
educational attainment.
And once I learned to remove
myself from the equation,
it changed from an
obligation or a fear
to actually something
that I felt honored to do,
that I could be the steward for
their educational attainment.
And if you say no,
you're not rejecting me.
You're just not choosing
to support them.
And so it drastically changed
my perception and approach
to fundraising.
But that only happened
because I said, look guys,
I'm bad at this, and
I need your help.
And so that was another chapter.
You know, it's later
on in the book.
Like, we're really
successful up to that point,
and it was important for
me to write, I admit.
Like even when people on the
outside think it's going well,
there's still major areas
of growth and improvement
that are needed.
FEMALE SPEAKER: On that same
kind of idea of fundraising,
social media has a huge--
ADAM BRAUN: Huge.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
--huge part of how
you developed your organization.
And up to a point you never
asked directly for money.
It was mainly through
social media tools.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, peer-to-peer
fundraising events,
stuff like that.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Can you talk a bit
about that, social
media, how you've
used it to grow
your organization?
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah, sure.
So we were one of the
first organizations
to really app
social and digital,
especially at a time when
it wasn't being done.
And so late '08 was, again,
a tough economic period,
especially in this city.
So the perception was you can't
waste your energy and time
on this crowd sourcing, small
donation, and like status
stuff.
You need to be kind of
hunkering down, and getting off
line checks from major donors.
And cause I was Zuckerberg's
year in college,
he was a sophomore at Harvard,
and I was a sophomore at Brown
when it launched, my friends
were all on Facebook,
and then early
adopters on pretty
much every other
platform, and so
I had to make two early bets.
And I think with any company, to
the point of the Wayne Gretzky
quote, you skate to where the
puck is going, not where it is.
And so my two early bets were,
one, that social media would
become integral to the fabric
of, not just our daily lives,
but business.
And so if I could build one of
the most engaged and largest
social media followings
around the organization,
that would be a
really valuable asset.
And then the second was
that cause marketing would
become really important for
large brands and start ups,
and that companies would
recognize that consumers will
change brands, if all
things are equal, if one has
a positive social
impact, and the best
way to do that is to partner
with a beautiful, well
branded organization.
And so with those two
kind of ideas in mind
I focused for the
first three years
not on high level fundraising,
but on building a community.
And now I was on
call with like think
of the most powerful
and maybe well-known
woman in the country,
her office, yesterday,
and the question that
they asked is, how are you
doing such an effective job
of engaging young people
and their families,
in particular?
And I had a call also
yesterday with a woman who
runs a really large business,
came to one of our events,
and said to me on the
phone, you know something,
I came to the event expecting
to learn about you guys.
I told my daughter I was
going, and she was like, yeah,
of course, how do you not
know about Pencils of Promise?
That's the first time
my daughter's ever
informed me about
an organization.
And so I focused on
creating an opportunity
for other individuals
to become heroes.
Any kind of dissection
of a great speech,
if you really break
it down, they usually
share this hero's journey.
This person comes up against
an obstacle, they fall back,
and then they overcome.
Great speeches actually
have the hero's journey
as the core element.
But it's not the speaker
on stage who's the hero,
it's the audience.
And that's what
eventually converts
the audience into action is the
opportunity for them to fulfill
this destined promise.
And so when I look
at social media,
the job is not to
highlight my story,
but it's actually
to get other people
to feel like their
story can succeed
through Pencils of Promise.
And digital and social is the
best way for us to enable it.
So that's always
been our approach
is to make other people heroes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
touched on cause marketing.
And it's something that
I'm really fascinated in.
And I love that it's
included in this book.
People that are in
for profit businesses,
how do you think that
they can-- what advice
do you have for people that
would want to incorporate cause
marketing into their
for-profit strategies?
ADAM BRAUN: I mean,
it's very simple.
You will make more money by
having positive social impact.
There's just no doubt about it.
I mean, all the
data is behind it.
If you look at the generational
wealth transfer that's
going to happen in the coming
years, trillions of dollars
are being transferred from
basically baby boomers
over to millennials,
and millennials just
have a clear preference to
support products, and goods,
and services that create
a positive social impact.
And so I advise
companies to focus
on what you do best, which
is probably sell your product
or service, but to partner
with great organizations
that do what they do best,
which is, in our case,
educating children.
And so if that resonates
with both your consumers
and your employees, then
find an organization that
fits your mission
or ethos and enable
them to do more great
work, and they in turn
can help you become
more profitable.
But part of the reason I
don't like the term nonprofit
is because we don't
exist to not profit.
We exist to create
positive social impact.
And there's this kind
of traditional approach
in the space that it's a one
way street, that because we
work with people in
poverty, like pity us.
Pity us as an organization
and the people we serve.
So you're kind of
obliged to help us maybe.
But I look at it as an
equal value exchange.
So Pencils of Promise can help
people make a lot more money.
And in doing so we
accomplish our mission,
which is educate more children.
And it should be
perceived that way.
I mean, our social
media following
is a valuable
marketing asset that we
can be help both us
and another company
achieve mutual objectives.
But it's really important
to align up front, and just
be really clear, and
say, look, you're
in this for x, we're in this
for y, and if both happen,
both of us end up
very happy, as well as
your employees and
your consumers.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
could talk to you
for like another
hour and half, but I
want to make sure we
have some time for Q&A.
So I'm going to just ask
a couple more questions,
and then I'll turn it over.
What's next for you?
ADAM BRAUN: The
next thing is what
we're calling our
innovation pilots.
So when we look at
the organization,
the mission was not
to build schools.
The mission was to help
in which every child has
access to quality education.
The good thing is we
now have a distribution
system of more than 200 schools.
And when I think
about all the changes
that have happened in
education since I started,
there's some really
fascinating stuff happening.
But it's almost impossible
to test it out domestically,
because it's either
too expensive,
or you have
entrenched interests,
like teachers' unions, and labor
unions, and parental groups,
and government
funded programs that
can't push the
bounds of innovation
rapidly and at low
cost, whereas we can.
And so what we're
doing is testing out
innovations in education within
three to five of our schools,
globally, across the
course of the next year.
So next month e-readers go
into classrooms in Ghana.
And we'll see what happens
when you have e-readers
for every single
student in one school,
and then a peer community
doesn't have access to it,
and what's the
educational outcomes that
are different because of it.
Long distance radio programming
into rural Guatemala.
We have 3D printers in Laos
that are producing literacy tool
kits, and then we're
using sign language
to teach early stage phonetics,
which is, in my mind,
one of the most
fascinating things that
is going to happen in ed period.
And we're pushing it forward.
And then there's a couple
others that were driving.
And that's what I'm
most excited about.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's sweet.
So on that, I'm going to ask
a couple questions of just
like finish this sentence style.
Keep it Googly.
Keep it light.
And then we'll open it
up for some questions.
I'm going to say, in your
tense, but you finish,
what inspires me the most is--
ADAM BRAUN: Listening
to people's stories
of fulfillment of purpose.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
am challenged by--
ADAM BRAUN: The people
I surround myself with.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The food I miss
most when I'm traveling is--
ADAM BRAUN: Chicken Parmesan.
No doubt.
AUDIENCE: You didn't
hesitate at all.
ADAM BRAUN: Nah.
My favorite food by far.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If I
weren't running an NGO,
or a for-purpose
organization, I would be--
ADAM BRAUN: Launching
a different company
that created the largest
positive social impact
possible.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Here at Google we
have something called Moonshots.
So my Moonshot is--
the biggest idea
you can possibly think
of to make happen.
ADAM BRAUN: I mean, I don't
even think this will happen.
I know it will happen
in my lifetime.
Quality education for
every child on Earth.
FEMALE SPEAKER: When
The Promise of a Pencil
is made into a movie, the
actor that will play me is--
ADAM BRAUN: Denzel Washington.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Amazing.
Oh, that's fantastic.
OK, I want to open up
to Q&A. There's a mic.
ADAM BRAUN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
First and foremost, I really
liked that you called attention
to something
[INAUDIBLE], which is
the false dichotomy of
doing well and doing good.
And so that's fantastic.
Having done some
international travel
and [INAUDIBLE]
work myself, I feel
like when you go there to
different countries, East
Africa, or wherever
you are, you are just
taking the sense of privilege,
whether the American privilege
or white male privilege.
What have you done
with Pencils of Promise
when it comes to creating
meaningful community
partnerships to empower
community members
to be engaged in what you're
doing versus what I think
a lot of companies fall into
to being like a White Savior
complex and helping and
making those changes.
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
So there's a really
powerful story
in the book, which is
about when I was 23,
I was in rural Guatemala.
And a man approached me
kind of by this lakeside,
and asked me to go live
with him for a while.
And I was like what is
this guy asking me to do?
But I took him up on the offer
cause the mantra at the time
was tourists see,
travelers seek.
And I went, and I live
with him for three days.
And he asked me to stay with
him because he had a large tape
cassette recorder, and a Bible.
And he wanted me to read his
Bible into this tape cassette
recorder.
And I couldn't really
understand why.
And then I came to realize he
had a big set of headphones,
and he was teaching
himself English.
And he was teacher.
And he couldn't pronounce
English very well.
So the goal was for him
to listen to my voice
pronouncing the words
properly so he could teach
himself to then teach his kids.
Completely changed my philosophy
on global development,
because he wasn't
asking for a handout.
He wanted the tools
to self-educate,
and then pass it down
to future generations.
And so that's informed every
one of the philosophies that's
launched the organization.
So, for example, we don't build
schools on behalf of villages.
Villages have to
commit to 10 to 20,
and now it's almost
always 20%, or more
of the funding for every
project that we undertake.
They have no spare cash,
because it's $300 to $500
in annual income for the
family in most communities
where we work.
So they make it up in
materials and labor.
So they collect the scrapwood,
the gravel, the cement.
And then more importantly
mothers and fathers
and elders and
siblings are physically
building the schools.
They provide almost
all the labor.
In Ghana it's 100% of labor
is provided by the community.
And that creates a sense of
real ownership and investment,
because we don't do
build trips, for example.
Like if somebody asks me, can
I go out and build a school,
and live in a village
for three weeks,
my answer is no, because I
want these communities to build
their own school so that
when it starts to break down
they don't say, hey, where was
that college kid from Wisconsin
that built my school,
because the piping's broken.
It's no, no.
I built my son's school.
It's starting to break down.
I need to fix it.
And he needs to
make sure he gets
his butt in the
classroom every day.
And so there's a
whole set of practices
in place across the organization
that insure local ownership
and sustainability.
AUDIENCE: So it's sometimes
difficult for somebody
like me to get a vision of
what these schools look like,
living in America [INAUDIBLE].
Can you tell us a story of
maybe one of the schools,
kind of paint a
picture of what it's
like for the kids,
who's teaching the kids,
and sort of how you, or your
work with your organization,
interact while they're there?
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
So we build between one
and six classroom schools.
The first one was like a
one classroom preschool.
Just getting started.
Now most of the prop
schools I would say
are four to six classrooms.
They serve anywhere
between 100 and 200 kids.
Once they're opened, most
likely 1,500 to 2,500 kids
over the life of that school.
And they're quality in material.
So it's rebar and cement.
It would look like, if you've
been to any kind of developing
world country, and there's
a quality structure there,
they're usually one floor.
In Guatemala we'll
build earthquake proof
two floors at times.
But they're the
nicest buildings,
I would say, in the
community, usually by far.
But they're built
completely for function.
So I've seen other
NGOs that spend
a ton of money on
huge bathrooms.
It's more important
for us to have
latrine for a boy and
a girl separately.
Because oftentimes when girls
start to go through they're
period they drop out
of school for those
four days out of the month,
and then they fall behind.
So we build separate bathrooms.
But the schools, let's see.
They're all public schools.
So they're under the education
ministry's jurisdiction.
The teachers are trained
by the education ministry
and then sent to
the schools, but we
realized that the
quality of teaching
wasn't as high as
we wanted it to be.
So we launched a teacher
training program.
That was our second program.
And then we saw that
when kids were completing
our primary schools, most of
the time, girls in particular,
were not continuing
with secondary school.
It was a small prohibitive
cost, like $250 in total.
So we launched a
scholarship program.
So that's our third program.
And then most of our
staff is international.
So there's about 15
here in New York.
There's almost 75 international,
and more than 90% of them
are from the countries
in which they work.
So it's Ghanaians
leading Ghanaian staff,
working with Ghanaian children.
It's not westerners showing
off and like passing out gifts.
And oftentimes our
staff actually comes
from the rural countryside,
you know, and grew up
in a bamboo hut, or a mud hut,
or a corrugated tin shack.
And so there are
about as familiar
as it gets with both the
needs and the preferences,
and the ideals, of
the communities.
AUDIENCE: So you just mentioned
sort of some of the impressions
that you had opening
schools, training teachers,
and you've also
talked about the angle
being quality education for all.
What's in five years?
What's in 10 years for you?
ADAM BRAUN: Well, I
bet some of the answers
are housed here at Google.
So one of my mentors
is a guy, Ray Chambers,
who's probably most
responsible at the end
of the day for
eradication of Malaria.
When there's gets to zero, Ray's
done it more than anybody else.
Co-founder of Malaria No More,
just this incredible history
of philanthropy.
It's like Buffet, and
Gates, and Ray is up there.
He's now the United
Nations Special
Envoy for Global Health.
So he's responsible
for achievement
of the four Millennium
Development Goals.
And he joined our board.
He's in the book as well.
So the thing that I
learned most from Ray
was to ask yourself
this question, which
is to think about where the
world is going in the next 10
years, what your goal
will evolve into,
as well as your resources and
your networks over those 10
years, and play the most
meaningful part in the world
that you're trying to
create over that period.
And what I've seen
him do so effectively
is create a convenient space
for ideas and individuals.
So they raised $6 billion
for eradication of Malaria,
which Ray has
charged forward on.
Malaria No More raises like
$10 or $15 million a year,
but they've been kind
of this focal point that
has rallied a community
around collective ideas.
And so when I think about
the next five or 10 years,
I know Pencils of Promise
will not build enough schools
to educate every child on Earth.
Even if we launch one of these
innovation pilots that works,
we're not the ones that're
going to scale it out
to reach every single child.
But the ambition is to
constantly push the space
forward and play the most
meaningful role possible
in the end goal, which is
quality education for all.
And so I don't think we'll
go into the advocacy space,
but I can see some of our ideas
being adopted through advocacy.
And the biggest thing that
we're going to provide value on
is changing people's thinking
around, one, the nonprofits,
and hopefully shift it towards
more of a for-puporse approach.
And then secondly, the idea
that like most nonprofits,
or for-purpose
organization, in our space
would commit to building
1,000 schools by 2017.
Like that would be it.
You know, we would be
building 1,000 schools,
but if that doesn't lead to
the mission being solved,
then we're not doing
the right thing.
And so my hope is that
five years from now
we're doing something that
I don't even know about.
Five years ago,
there's no chance
I would have told you about
e-readers in classrooms,
because it just
wasn't even an idea.
And so my hope is we're almost
like, if you watch a baby
walking, you know, like
they're almost falling forward,
but they always somehow
catch themselves.
And the idea is to
move the organization
with that type of momentum.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I was wondering if you
could say a little bit more
about your data-driven approach
to solving [INAUDIBLE].
It seems to be a common
theme now in a lot of NGOs.
ADAM BRAUN: Completely.
So I think the Gates
Foundation has probably
moved the space in that
direction more than any other,
because they've just applied
so much rigorous data driven
monitoring and evaluation to
the way that they issue grants,
as well as Robin Hood.
Robin Hood's about as
data-driven as it gets.
So one of the things that's
really important to us
is that we're not purely driven
by passion, but by commitment
to results.
And so we track about
25 different metrics
in every community after
a school is opened.
So that's everything
from teacher attention,
to student attendance,
to literacy progression,
grade progression, numeracy.
And what we're seeing is
some really compelling data.
So kids that go
through classrooms
where we've provided
our teaching training
outperform peer communities
three to one on test scores.
85% of the communities
where we work
are reporting
increases in literacy.
And kids in Pencils
of Promise schools
are progressing from one
grade to the next at two times
the national average.
And so that to me is what's,
truthfully, most important.
So this is a little bit jargony,
but the nonprofit space always
celebrates outputs.
And so the output would be
broke ground on 200 schools,
22,000-plus kids
in our classrooms,
and 15 million education
hours delivered.
And those are
nice, flashy stats,
and people say, wow,
that's really great.
But the analogy of that
would be for a company
to purely be based on the
amount of employees they have.
Or, you know, I define
it to background.
So it'd be like someone
saying, hey, I just
launched an investment fund,
and we have $25 million
under management.
Now, that's great,
but all that matters
is what's the performance
of your investment strategy.
So if you have $25 million under
management but you're down 30%
on the year, you're
not doing a good job.
And yet the nonprofit
space kind of
has this free pass, where
people assume, oh, I gave $100,
I got my $100 tax deduction.
I did good in the world.
And oftentimes that $100 is
either used ineffectively--
sometimes it has
unintended consequence
that are adversely
effecting the communities.
And so our commitment
is to always stay
held accountable to
the results themselves.
And so we kill programs often.
We mapped out all
of our programs,
and we were doing something,
it was called Sister Schools.
So we pairing together schools
in low income communities,
in the Bronx, and Queens,
and parts of the city,
and parts of California
with some of our schools
internationally.
And, you know, parents
and individuals
were like, can we do pen pals?
We did it.
We thought it was a great idea.
And then when we mapped
it out on a two by two,
and kind of did
consulting style work,
we realized, all right,
this is actually not
advancing our mission
very effectively.
It's not advancing the
fundraising component
of the organization.
And it's a huge effort on behalf
of our time, energy, resources,
our staff.
And so we stopped the program
because it was ineffective.
Now, it would be
nice for me to show
you pictures of kids in
the Bronx communicating
with kids in rural Laos,
and everyone would say,
oh, I feel so good.
But it was an ineffective
usage of our dollar.
And so when you have
a data-driven approach
I think you make those
emotionally tough decisions.
But if you're committed to
the mission achievement,
then it's a no-brainer.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted
to sort of understand
a question that you asked.
[INAUDIBLE]
ADAM BRAUN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I wanted
to like focus it around
how we could apply technology
advances to this mission.
And I want to ask the
question this way.
Just sort of think about
some big things that we do,
and [INAUDIBLE].
If you could have a bunch of
[INAUDIBLE] for six months,
what would you have them do?
ADAM BRAUN: Great question.
So the underlying,
I guess, variable
is whether there's Wi-Fi
access in our communities,
which there is currently not.
And so the first
thing I would say
is bringing Wi-Fi access
to every community
in which we worked.
If I could get that
in itself, like
that would be the Moonshot.
I think that, whatever,
it's something
like 4 billion people are
not currently connected.
And so if we could connect every
single one of our communities
into the internet
in some capacity,
that would be the dream.
But because it's probably,
let's say, five years away--
it's not that far away--
but in the meantime
I think there's some really
interesting capabilities
around mobile access
in communities,
and provision of
content, quality content.
Because what we
see is most people
have mobile phones,
certainly in Ghana.
They're starting to get them in
Guatemala at pretty high rates.
Laos is less frequent, but
somebody in the community
has a mobile phone.
And there should be some
type of content delivery
system within feature phones.
So right now people are mainly
focused on smart phones,
but the communities where
we work don't have those.
So I would almost ask
engineers to say, OK,
what is the mobile
capacity going
to be in this community
in the next three years?
And then how do we build
a content delivery system
so that they can self educate?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: So you have these
organizations like [INAUDIBLE].
What's your take on, since
you're [INAUDIBLE] organization
maybe it's going to
be really good at it
at the end of the year.
What's your thinking
on [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM BRAUN: Sure.
So, one, I would
never personally knock
anyone that's trying to create a
positive influence in the world
and in the lives of others.
So it's hard for me to say
this is a bad organization
unless they actually
do bad things.
My personal preference,
my genuine belief,
is that the single
most powerful way
to bring positive
aid to the world
is through greater
access of opportunity,
to not dictate what somebody
should or shouldn't do,
but purely to give them
the opportunity to choose.
And there's no more
powerful way to do that
than through education.
The second thing is from
a data-driven approach.
The only measured
way that has proven
effective to raise
a country's GDP
is through greater access
to education and attainment
through educational achievement
of primary age children.
It's just the only
thing that's been
proven to lift up
GDP's consistently.
And so when I look
at that, and I think,
OK, education, now I
have the data behind it.
I have the personal
preference towards it.
And in my opinion it's
the only root cause
that lifts up all others.
So when you look at
discrimination issues,
when you look at
disease, education
is the one that just
has some type of kind
of residual impact on the rest.
And my second thing
is around health.
Health and education
are tied hand in hand.
But my personal passion has
always been around education.
But if somebody
works on-- I mean,
there's an MIT study
that tried to say,
what is the most dollar for
dollar effective intervention,
[INAUDIBLE].
Now, that said,
that's like in a lab.
It's theoretical.
It's think-tanks
putting it together.
But for me it's
always been access
to quality education, and
in particular, for youth.
And so I wouldn't knock
any other organization,
but I think there's something
powerful within that.
And the last part for me is
that the former CEO of Malaria
No More said this
to me outright.
He said education is the
most stupidly solvable issue
of our time, because
we have everything
needed to educate every child.
So with malaria
there's vaccinations.
There are bed nets that
may or may not work.
With water you have to dig for
aquifers that you're not sure
if they're going to show up.
With prevention
of AIDS or cancer,
again, you'll have
to do research.
And diabetes, we just don't
have the solution known yet.
With education we have
everything, right now,
to educate every child on Earth.
And within that knowledge
gives me confidence
that it's the thing that I like
to work on, because I believe
I can solve it-- not
I, but collectively
we together-- can
actually solve this,
which gives me a
lot of excitement.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well thank you guys
so much for coming.
Thank you for coming
and talking with us.
It's been really, really
cool to have you here.
ADAM BRAUN: Thank you guys.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Books are
available in the back,
and thank you so much.